hey everyone Marcelo right whale here
comedian and opinionated [ __ ] with my
new series you welcome I don't know who
the [ __ ] you were [ __ ] before this
but this ain't for me
exactly not with that hairdo um and this
is a series where I invite some of my
favorite comedians who just so happens
to be women sometimes boys I don't know
anything about sports but and we talk
about whatever we want to talk about
without any judgement it's not really
cover up the scars on your face I'm a
little bit of a judgmental [ __ ] but in
the best way possible
right so bad about myself eating a
burger masturbating shift maybe it's
funny maybe no it's funny it's always
gonna be funny you're gonna learn
something there's a wiener surprise sex
ed 1994 so tune in you welcome [ __ ]
[Music]
today's guests we have the incredibly
funny deborah DiGiovanni there's a great
comedian she has a new comedy central
digital series called stuff and dev
check that out and quit to Brunson
another great comedian actor or slash
slash slash lots of things a black lady
sketch show on HBO check that out
welcome ladies never being here enjoy
having us what's going what's going on
ladies what's happening with you I just
came from my a new chiropractor I've
ever been to a camera head yeah oh yeah
okay yeah I was I was rear-ended about
two months two months ago in an uber
with that with a car to go that's
another story
he's I went in today it's a new guy I
he's so hot it's terrifying I mean is
this something that we didn't know about
that chiropractors are like ridiculously
on I don't think it's it I don't think
any doctor should be allowed to be hot
oh yeah
yeah immediately and he's like I'm gonna
put some heating pads I was like you
don't need it like I'm literally boiling
right now so on there's like twice the
week I was like it's a date I like I
said that I was like I have to leave
immediately God working on that I'm just
I'm out here I've been in the house for
like three days straight working so this
is my first experience out in a long
time I know that you're working I
thought you gonna be like I've been the
holidays depressed oh no no no we're
going this is I feel like I'm fortunate
to be one of my not depressed people oh
good I feel not it feels like I'm crying
it was weird it feels worried I'm really
enjoying it but I you realize that
people around you if they're not happy
that it really makes you feel like [ __ ]
talking I know you know me but I hate
that though I like I want to celebrate
people's happiness success and joy I
really do I am good she's getting that
back what was your last day job I would
always was receptionist for years and
years and I think was it leave I think
was an advertising agency yeah so answer
yeah girls whenever I would leave a job
they would cry you know not a job my
last date my last day job was actually
BuzzFeed so wasn't like good well yeah
yeah it was a day job they didn't feel
like a day job it definitely was a nine
to six so that was a when if you have to
get up at a certain time it's a
dangerous it's my last day job was a
busboy it was a busboy in Los Angeles oh
my god I loved it she really did well
cuz I used to manage at be assistant
manager of a bank and I was [ __ ]
stressed
[ __ ] yeah million millions of dollars
stress me out notice we're going all
right so I want to jump into these
topics the bagel boss yeah Wow the bagel
video went viral recently or this
gentleman in this bagel shop you should
be dead that's okay okay first of all a
wild video but I really wanted to bring
up his individual plight of having a
unique body type okay which the three of
us can identify with three of us do have
a unique body butters why did you look
at me oh I have never thrown such a
disbelieve I'm 411
she's 411 so smaller than the bagel boss
yeah but the thing is for a man it
really is tough territory when that
builds up because being a short man is
difficult yeah he might need to talk it
out with someone seriously yeah yeah his
issues and and learn to channel them
into finding someone who loves him for
him because a woman is considered petite
and red and I'm sure that there must be
moments where just like okay I'm
adorable stop yeah what do they treat
you almost like a little too adorable
yeah you know nothing of me to ever have
his his directly correlated with love he
doesn't think I can be loved and I've
never felt that way right right right
makes me say it's I mean it's a little
different he's short and there's nothing
he can do about it my unique body type
is this I didn't just wake up be like oh
my god that was you know it's been years
of trust so I invested in return yeah
but I still at the same time like I do
um like I don't want to be a fetish I am
and the one thing right now like of this
moment that is so that lurks me now it's
because God bless know we're so body
positive and it's all but I'm even like
I'm the wrong kind of big Jimmy I'm not
I'm not I'm just a girl with troubles
you're me nice that's that's it so even
then I have that moment of like like
it's just it's about my dismay a little
it's also proof yet that whole movement
is full of [ __ ] it's better than not it
is definitely definitely when you want
when you see like the plus-size models
they're just they're always like yeah
you think that you are to enjoying here
like Jessica Rabbit land for you like oh
yeah yeah and it's like wow those
movements are good it also sometimes are
scary cuz it feels like is okay but is
it a fad are you guys like similar
things like with the not about bodies
but like with the black woman's movement
okay like but it's like okay but are you
really interested or are you just
finding a new market right now right so
the interesting thing to me for the
bagel boss is he's an exact type of dude
that will hit on me at a bar and without
any hesitation I'm six-two and always in
heels
yeah and he's exactly the type of dude
that's like hey it's mad at me that's
why the whole like Oh women reject me is
wild to me because a lot of the times a
lot of short dudes have way more
confidence than any other type of dude
I've ever met in my whole life and
they're the ones that like they get mad
at Emily
[ __ ] I'm six-two why do I have to be
the one yeah where's that couldn't get
like a five seven have you dated tall
guys I have updated many we're taller
than me I've dated men who are like I
think the shortest is five seven okay it
was really funny because like sometimes
well one time you stood on the curb and
I like stood in the street and he could
leave his apartment and I would you know
that thing that your parents do when
your kids are just like they crouch down
there like yeah I would do that to him
yeah I was like producer Jermaine Dupri
recently went on a tirade about how all
female rappers just rap about their
[ __ ] and they're all strippers and
whatever the [ __ ] you said which you can
go [ __ ] himself that's not true if you
like rap or any type of music you can
always find me the other voices it's not
that hard this is something that has
been said a lot about women comedian and
so I want to know what your guys's
experience has been with this because I
know that every woman comic you have to
go through a journey about talking do
you want to talk about sex you know I
want to talk about sex I definitely I
definitely know that like it's so funny
because men can say whatever they want
on stage and it's fine but if a woman
does one dirty joke she's considered
filthy yeah she's labeled filthy blue
there was a club when I first got here
there's a club
outskirts of the city and I was after I
did a set great set one of the owners of
the club banned me from telling a joke
not even a dirty joke not and he said
you can't say this because I say the
word uterus in it and he said you'll
please never do that joke again wait now
living that long ago no I'm talking like
five years ago that's crazy uterus okay
so it's you know no one was to hear that
it's a bit too much the dude before me
he had done his entire set on a prostate
exam frosty
the entire his entire seven minutes and
I said uterus once yeah I mean I hate
this topic of discussion I just think
it's so tired yeah you know before the
show started I was just telling myself
about how much I hate that we have to
continue to carry the burden of
representation yeah I know what happened
forever but it is what it is
it's just tired and it's just a way for
us to be boxed in yeah which is
essentially what Jermaine Dupri was
doing yeah he really shouldn't be
talking he shouldn't be the authority
about what hip-hop is right now right
hip-hop is a wave checking for the nude
range are you guys cuz I'm right I was
what our demand opinion I have a moment
before I listen to music with a live
Jermaine's opinions on music right now
no I asked you first Corral and it's not
that men can't talk in it because I
actually enjoy hearing the current like
power players right Duke it out but
mainly because they're part of the
conversation and I think it's similar
with comedy but the interesting thing is
that even in Japan in Jermaine Dupri
case and even in comedy I mean some of
the most popular women in the industry
are talking about sex yeah very often
exactly it's who is not putting other
voices forward yeah that's the real
issue here that he Jermaine Dupri I mean
he's a mainstream artist and so he's
only looking at mainstream artists like
he doesn't he's not looking he's not
actively pursuing no name or tarawa yes
not looking for those voices because
that doesn't interest him he's not
probably visually stimulated by them so
why would he listen to what they have to
say and that's a lot of male consumption
of women a way we've been talking but
anyhow the um yeah I just think the
thing is so so what that the mainstream
artists I love you so so much
no but so what the mainstream artists
are talking about right so what like and
why does it concern you and the ripple
brought up the good point that shouldn't
even be brought up all this is so tired
Fisher like dying the whole world is
dying right yeah you male artists have
been
talking about this [ __ ] for years yeah
for years and it never was a problem
yeah and then we get our nice like we
get our J Coles and we get our nods is
there people who aren't and it's like
yeah we welcome that too right
so shut the [ __ ] up yeah not even know
what to say and I respect you mean to be
very much Jermaine if you're watching
this love your album with Mariah Carey
and all the other artists you've worked
with but shut the [ __ ] up I actually saw
him in person at an event and he looks
you look like a tiny scared wet rat what
women are doing so now we're going into
the Q&A and if you want to submit a
question send to you welcome questions
at gmail.com hopefully we can answer it
and if you are sending really intense
questions and you need help please seek
professional help we've been getting
some pretty intense questions guys I'm
not a therapist what are some ways that
I can bounce back from pursuing my
initial career path and failing big time
how can I find the inspiration to pursue
my dreams when reality is so crushingly
brutal and the local creative resources
and career seem very limited or
non-existent oh wow oh wow I think it's
a matter of tenacity I think that is
what separates a lot of people from
dating and from failing yeah is
maintaining that tenacity I don't want
to call it hunger cuz I hate when people
refer to it as a because it's like
you're not hungry it's like you want to
do the thing that you love yeah so you
have to keep going and there is there's
you know fear is a big part of it and
the other the thing about fear is that
it's it's so there's an expression fear
is 10,000 miles high in 10,000 miles
wide but paper-thin enemy you walk
through it and it's done it yeah there
we go
you know and so I think that like right
now she's probably whoever this person
is is probably in a lot of fear am I
gonna feel the next one the beautiful
thing is that no one remembers and
nobody cares so whatever happened in the
failure it is nobody else cares no one
is worrying about it because we all only
care about ourselves yes
take that and be like no one is going
never win she no one cares it's over so
you have a clean slate and I think
really especially the three of us
sitting here - what you want I am so
happy that we live one time okay that's
all I believe we live one time just do
what you want life is too short to hate
your job is it not yes yeah so do what
you want that's it yeah I've talked
about this before anyone I was on all
fantasy everything podcast but like when
the worst thing that could happen is
you're poor yeah so if like if you
become poor you've been poor before that
is literally the worst thing that could
happen you got pursuing your dreams and
it's not that bad like you're you'll
always be fine I'll always find a way
yeah work yeah two roommates you got to
do I'm yeah okay always have like a
timeline in their head and they're
thinking they should probably have this
thing accomplished by this time in their
life and sometimes it's an invisible
timeline that we haven't actually set
out Wow but we think we should have a
certain thing by a certain time but a
lot of times like get ready getting rid
of that timeline is really beneficial
yeah because it really is only you who
thinks you probably need to do this
thing by tomorrow yeah where is um you
know if you give yourself more time you
could accomplish it and yeah yeah yeah I
agree
yeah next question been dating my
boyfriend for a year now should I marry
him get his green card green card right
you're Canadian what do you think no
don't do that that's a terrible idea
I mean what's the question again she's
been dating her boyfriend for a year
should I marry him so he can get his
green card do you want to marry him yeah
the question you want a man do you wanna
marry him what are you talking what is
marriage do it does it even have any
value anymore
well then I'm saying like what Samir
like to me the two are unrelated I've
been dating my boyfriend for a year
should I marry him to me those are like
not related you could be dating a man
for seven years why do you wanna marry
and should you actually ever ask someone
should I marry him no no it's okay I'm
latina people who have married for green
cards and they are still together oh so
like I'm not totally against it and I
also know that there are people that get
married for less oh gosh and then they
get divorced quickly so it's like that's
why I'm like oh he's married
who cares dude you want you shouldn't be
asking us cuz just do what you want yeah
she's asking she wants permission she's
trying to she wants try that yeah
relieve guilt and that's you don't have
to yeah hopefully you're a grown woman
do what you want if it lasts a year
god bless who cares right I mean
seriously if you're divorced in four
months we don't care I don't care okay I
do I don't I think it's nice when people
married so that other people can be
citizens who cares this country it has
plenty how did fellow bad [ __ ] keep
their bad [ __ ] feel I'm proud of the
life that I have I live my own I have
amazing friends I've got a ton of
hobbies I hold down a job I'm almost out
of student loan debt and I know I'm a
cutie but sometimes I get incredibly
depressed because I even never had a
long-term relationship I'm 36 which I
know that this is just society's
[ __ ] and there's nothing wrong with
being single I know that I'm awesome but
sometimes I have a really hard time with
her money myself how can I keep my bad
[ __ ] attitude because being a bad [ __ ]
being a fat [ __ ] is whack especially
since I know a relationship isn't a
magic stick should I write I'm the
badass [ __ ] and nobody can take that
from me and lipstick in my bathroom
mirror oh my god
Quinta has a lot to say about this
what's your question what's her she just
basically is how do i free my hot here's
the thing she's asking you how to not be
blue because she knows that her life is
great and we talked about this we're all
happy right yeah everybody's blue at
some point like feeling it's sad like
yeah and everyone gets lonely you
yeah that's normal and natural yeah
right so she's just wondering how to
maintain being a bad [ __ ] but part of
it yeah why do being a bad [ __ ] is
knowing and accepting how you feel in
the moment whether it's sad whether it's
not whether it's horny whatever it is
you [ __ ] deal with it head-on and
then you move on from that yeah that's
how you maintain being a bad [ __ ] yeah
honestly and through to yourself yeah I
feel like I have so many questions for
her but I feel like I can guess her sex
life and I think that it might be tied
to want like the idea of one other
person to fulfill it because she's
talking about being lonely no and I'm
not having a long-term relationship but
like I think that sometimes young women
are ideas get tied to like relationships
relationships happiness with them not
yeah and sometimes if you free yourself
from that kind of cloud you get to have
more fun yes sexually it with your
short-term relationships and then that's
fine in between the long-term ones and
when a long-term one does come it's like
great but I think that's something a lot
I also figure you also think that whole
thing about like you know when you start
focusing on something it frees
everything else up like there's
something about that that it's like when
you put too much pressure on something
yeah it just makes it harder and yeah
miserable that means everyone boyfriend
came in and then they want because they
did the energy of you living your life
honestly and having fun is good energy
you're just if you just enjoying your
life better people come into your life
right but like really enjoying it not
just have some say yeah safely yeah I'm
about to be 35 and I've never had a
long-term relationship so I totally
relate to the like the idea of like
feeling like blue because I'm not in
this relationship but it's like it is a
matter of focusing on what is positive
and what is good and also sometimes
first of all I hear people ask me why
I'm out on date
apps have you guys heard yourselves talk
about your dating life you're not oh my
god appealing all my friends I'm like if
you you don't song you're having any fun
oh yeah no I've never been on yeah maybe
it doesn't sound appealing so for me
it's and it's not even like I'm waiting
for the right person it's more just like
I don't even know if the right person is
out there I also feel like a complete
person myself yeah so it's like what do
you have a point of bringing something
in this and maybe messing it up yeah you
know being complete when your own is
really important that's the key yeah
yeah it is I think so too
that's the question that she doesn't
want to admit do I even need a boyfriend
yeah that's the question needs to ask
herself yeah what what benefit does it
bring you which is why I'm Quinta
Brunson and I'm voting for male
prostitution to be legal hi kidding no I
don't get it but hello there we go
that's two votes right there Prince
Prince in 2020 ha ha ha
pp I think you should read it put it on
your shoulders alright well thank you so
much for being here
you guys you welcome [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] oh it's so amazing thank you so
much subscribe below catch the ladies
wherever they're at
follow them online
[Music]